foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm Ramsey personality George
Campbell Join This Hour by best-selling
author and host of the Ken Coleman Show
Ken Coleman himself and we are here to
take your calls at triple eight eight
two five five two two five if you've got
money questions I'm here for you if
you've got questions around purpose and
career and work and is now the time to
switch jobs they just get laid off Ken
is here to help so give us a call Triple
eight eight two five five two two five
you know what George I've learned in my
life that every time I've had some
personal growth an area of my life where
I've grown personally I've always see
professional and financial growth as a
result of that and uh so for if you're
new to the audience I'm your personal
growth coach your work on purpose More
Money More meaning guy so I've always
loved love to take those calls and feel
stuck let's get you unstuck today so you
ready to roll I'm ready you look
fantastic in your denim shirt thank you
Ken yeah wow man
see see what I did there good to have
friends make George feel good about
himself so that now he gives better
advice taking him back well let's see if
Kevin gets that advice he's in
Turnersville New Jersey Kevin welcome to
the show how you doing
hey George hey Ken thanks for taking my
call I really appreciate this what's
going on huh all right so um I just
finished baby step three I'm on the baby
step four five and six I don't have to
do five I don't have any kids in school
but I'm about to start adding 15 into my
401k okay and I lost 401ks that I get a
six percent match one okay but because
I'm 55 years old I'm allowed to do what
they call a um catch-up contribution
and my center of contribution is another
7 500 that I can contribute to that for
the year do I do that or do I just stay
with the 15 take the six percent match
and then work on the house with the
extra money that I get for my for my
monthly um pay income how much do you
have in retirement right now
I'm sitting there like four 400k
oh nice okay I thought you were gonna
tell me you had nothing in there so that
makes me feel a whole lot better what's
left on the mortgage
uh it's about 190.
and what's your household income
uh right now it's sitting at like close
to 100. okay like 99. love it and uh do
you see yourself continuing to work for
another five ten years what's that
looking like
but you know
well I would stay the course uh that the
latter on what you said which is 15 uh
that's going to get you it won't get you
quite close to maxing out the Roth 401k
but with that match you're getting 100
return on that six percent which is
great and so with all the margin you
have beyond that I'm going to throw it
at the house you've got 190 left on the
house you make a hundred I would set a
real hard goal of saying hey in four
years I want this mortgage gone
okay all right that puts you at 59. okay
I was at three years with them I love
that but let's go for three years
because then three years from now then
we can start maxing out the Roth 401k
doing all of the contributions we can
with the the ketchup there's also other
ways you can um
really kick start that retirement which
is backdoor Roth IRAs Mega backdoor Roth
IRA so there's a lot of options for you
maxing out your hsas another great thing
to do at that point but I would focus on
that house payoff and use that and
dangle that carrot of more contributions
coming up in three years
got it all right thanks for the clear
path that that's that that's where
that's what that's what I needed I'm
glad I called today you got it Kevin we
are here to help my friend appreciate it
all right let's move on to Billy in
Atlanta Billy welcome to the show
I really appreciate it guys thank you so
much sure what's going on today
uh so just a question around 401 having
to move it out of a old employment uh
retirement fund and gonna take a penalty
regardless of leaving it there or into
removing it because the new job doesn't
offer one for two years
so advice on that do I leave it there
and just continue with the market up and
downs or do I take that full penalty on
a cash withdrawal to pay off a little
bit of debt why do you need to withdraw
why don't you just do a direct rollover
to an IRA and avoid all penalties
according to the retirement plan now
even doing a rollover to the IRA
requires a penalty they don't have that
option pre-built in and it would be
similar to taking a cash withdrawal or
withdrawing it from the current plan and
starting a new traditional plan I have
never heard of an employer not allowing
you to do a direct rollover without
penalties
you're 100 sure
I am pretty sure I spent countless hours
on with this retirement plan and I'm I'm
about 99 sure there is a penalty to roll
it over into more a traditional style
okay well either way whatever it's going
to take to get that into an IRA that
would be my move versus moving it over
to your new employer so you already have
the new job
I do yeah
similar retirement plan there
uh similar I didn't of course I don't
know all the options yet just because
I'm not to that time point but from what
I've seen uh it is very similar okay
well I would also get in touch with a
smartvester pro and see what your
options are they can they'll be more
knowledgeable on the ins and outs of
401K plans and help you navigate this to
limit any fees or penalties you would
pay
okay
because I've never heard of this where
you can't do a direct rollover
do you know what the penalty is
18 percent
18 in penalties for doing a direct
rollover
yes oh my goodness all right I mean I'm
looking into it here to see if that's a
thing out there I've never heard of this
Ken have you ever heard of penalties I
haven't and I know you're 99 sure but I
can't tell you how many times I've told
Stacy my wife that I'm 100 sure that I'm
putting this thing together properly all
to find out that I wasn't sure at all I
I really do think that you need to speak
with one or two of our smartvestor Pros
in your area do you have a smart Master
Pro from Ramsey
uh no I do not I this is a phone call
uh ramseysolutions.com your area there a
lot of smartvestor Pros have a
conversation with them that's what they
do these are people that we vetted they
don't work for us they're they're
independent or they work for
organizations but they they teach the
way we teach and they are experts on
this they need to look at the fine print
they need to advise you on this I'm a
little skeptical and I just know how
many times I've been 99 sure and all to
find out that I was 100 wrong yeah I
can't imagine that every employee that's
ever left that company has taken an 18
hit on their retirement account when
they leave
it just doesn't make sense to me so I'm
not saying you're wrong it may just be a
weird fluke in in their system and their
contract but I would probably because
what everything I'm saying is a direct
rollover is exactly what helps you do
this without penalty without creating
taxable events yeah yep okay
wishing you the best uh best of luck man
yeah just on a side note even cashing it
out to pay off roughly twenty thousand
fifty thousand in total total debt and
still adding some of the bank account
wouldn't be an option no I would
definitely not do that it's not worth
the penalties and fees you're unplugging
all the growth and compound interest
that could be happening use your future
income in any savings liquid cash to do
that but do not Rob your future to pay
off the past that is a bad idea my
friend thanks for the call more of your
calls coming up triple eight eight two
five five two two five this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
everything's backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings
visit blinds.com to save up to 45 off
everything
site-wide go to blinds.com now to learn
more
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show I'm
George Campbell Join This Hour by Ken
Coleman opened phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five you
jump in we'll talk about your life your
work your career your purpose your money
we are here for you to help you take
that right Next Step our question of the
day is brought to you by Ottomans
Ottomans when you just need to get your
feet up that's what they're there for
yup love it today's question comes from
Al in Virginia he asks what is your
recommended percentage of income going
into retirement if you're debt free and
you own your home is it still 15
currently I'm right at 30 and I'm 51
years old with north of 1 million
dollars in assets fifty percent of which
is in a 401k is it possible to invest
too much
I love this question and I love where Al
is at financially so if you're tracking
with the baby steps Al is at baby step
seven the final baby step because he has
a paid for home no debt he's got money
in the bank and so at baby step seven
you can invest more than 15 to your
heart's desire it's build wealth and
give and there's no parameters around
that and it's for a good reason it looks
different for everyone
so is it possible to invest too much I
think it's a great question because on
one hand on the financial side no you
could have five million dollars you
could have ten million dollars from
retirement you could have 20 million
dollars it only gives you more options a
bigger Legacy and more responsibility to
manage but it's a great problem to have
yeah it really is and again it just
speaks to uh people who are new to this
process when you get a question like
this and you hear this like this is
possible you can do this there's a
reason why there's seven baby steps and
I love that it's a way for many of you
who feel like this is so very far off to
realize it's attainable well and at 51
with a million dollars in assets wow
that's an incredible Milestone it's
probably not enough to retire off of for
the next 40 years if you want to have a
really great retirement so well let's
also point out that he's 51 and then you
know average length of life I mean he's
still got a long way to go in a good way
he's going to keep racking it up 40 50
years ego how much do I need to live and
so A good rule of thumb
is to go how much do I want to live off
in retirement in yearly income multiply
that by 25 and that gives you a really
good number and here's why there's
something called the Trinity study out
there Ken that said if you peel off four
percent of your nest egg every year your
initial balance should remain where it
is nice so if you have a million bucks
you can peel off four percent Without
Really Ever touching that million
dollars that's a great exercise and so
as far as investing too much I would
always caution you to invest more than
you think you'll need because taxes are
going to continue to go up inflation is
going to continue to go up you don't
know what's going to happen in the
future where you're going to want to
live and so I always want more options
versus less now here's why I will say
you're you're investing too much if you
are miserable in your everyday life but
you were at least a great saver but you
your wife wants to go on vacation and he
won't take her even though you don't
have any debt and you've got a million
dollars
that's where I would say let's dial it
back so we can actually enjoy the next
few years of our life while we're still
young and able Let's Travel let's do
those things so if you're allocating to
spending into giving then the rest can
go to saving and you can do that with an
intentionality and no regret yeah I love
that plan and again very simple that
four percent rule is a great rule for
people to get an idea of what I want to
get to so I can live the life that I
think I want to absolutely and uh if you
were going well that feels impossible
because I'm 51 I have nothing saved
there is still hope for you we might
need to reset the expectations of what
we thought retirement would be we might
need to look at a different place to
live to downsize our house to downsize
our life but you can still retire with
dignity if you follow this Ramsay plan
if you get out of debt and have a pile
of money in the bank and you're
investing towards the future future you
can still have a great retirement Here's
a thought just a thought George we we
should probably talk about this sometime
on the show uh
we are seeing Baby Boomers retire at
record rates so we're kind of in the
middle of this and it's going to be
interesting to see over the next five to
ten years
or let's call it 15 years what does the
data show us about these large amounts
of of baby boomers uh retiring because
retiring if it is the notion that it is
I'm not going to ever work again
and um I'm just going to sit around the
house and watch TV take a good afternoon
nap
that's resigning
that I'm old and I'm dying
I I think retiring needs to have a
component of certainly hobbies and
things that you enjoy where you are
active mentally and physically but I
also think it needs to have a level of
contribution and while it may not be
working the same amount of hours
um I I when I look at retirement age it
has has no picture at all with me not
working
am I working less
am I working at a uh slower Pace sure
am I playing more and traveling more
absolutely but contributing through some
type of work it's got to be the case uh
and I just think aging studies if you
want to go look at these things do your
own homework it shows that staying
active is not just go to your swim class
at the YMCA and play golf with the guys
on Saturday morning so I just think it's
really interesting for those of you that
like I'm 51 and I'm just starting you
know what it's possible for you to
enter into retirement age have money
work some
and still have a great lifestyle it's
not all on I gotta just live off the
401K that may be controversial to some
but I just think we're gonna see that
that shifts with younger Generations
absolutely and there's only so much on
Netflix before you get bored oh you need
to have a little bit of purpose in life
so great reminders there Ken all right
let's go to the phones Mitch is in
Atlanta Mitch welcome to the show
hey how you doing thank you oh man this
is incredible thanks for taking my call
oh happy to do it thanks for calling wow
here's where I am I in 2008 I'm a
full-time realtor I've been real for 25
years and 2008 nine when the market
change I lost everything so I did
foreclosure uh year and a half later I
bought a house of forty thousand dollars
and my parents are renovator so they
came down and renovated the house so the
houses I have no debt you know pay the
house off it's probably worth about 300
000 now and I have no no debt you know I
do a debit card I got 6 000 in checking
I've got 23 000 in savings
I I have a lot of free time I'm still
work full-time as a realtor but I have a
lot of free time and
I don't know what to do now I don't know
if I know if I can score anymore you
know no debts uh zero uh and I don't I
don't spend on anything I don't pay I
don't buy anything
I just don't know what to do at this
point if my my parents went if they pass
away which would be the worst day of my
life they have about 13 houses so me and
my fam my brother my sister would we'll
do be looking pretty good
with money when you say you don't know
what to do do you mean do with your day
because you're just not interested in
selling houses anymore is that what
you're saying no I do I do I just I want
to have a retirement and I just don't
know where to how to do it I mean
you know I've got the 60 I've got money
in the bank but I need retirement and I
don't know it sounds like the real
estate properties would become part of
your portfolio to cash flow some
retirement correct
yes but for now let's say your parents
live much longer what would you do if
you retired tomorrow where would your
income come from
um
well I I do I do cars as a hobby have
you been investing at all into the
market no I no that's the problem I
don't know where to invest and what to
do I I have zero clue about what to do
from here so you have no 401K no
retirement Accounts at all no IRAs no
okay that would be a good first step how
old are you
I'm 59 I guess I'm at step seven of your
baby steps how much cash you have in the
bank
I got 22 000 in savings and six thousand
checking
that would be basically your emergency
fund and spending money maybe a little
bit more so we still need to figure out
retirement income what are you making
per year on average
50 between 50 and 60 000. so you're not
selling a ton of homes
no I'm not doing a lot
um Market's crazy it's up and down but
no I'm not doing a ton of a ton of
business well I tell you what this is
complex so George let's hold uh Mitch
over because there's a lot of people
that are in his shoes Mitch George's
going to walk you through step by step
what you need to do uh because there is
time we were just talking about this and
you've got unlimited potential with that
income especially in the Atlanta area so
uh let's hang on absolutely yeah there's
a financial component here and there's
also a purpose component that I want Ken
to dig into because you're 59 you got a
whole life ahead of you and you're going
I don't know man I don't know what's
next and we want to help you with that
Mitch so hang on the line we'll be right
back here on the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you that's why you need to get
in touch with Churchill Mortgage to make
sure you do this right these guys are
awesome they'll help you get on a
smarter mortgage plan because they're
committed to doing what's right for you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show I'm George
Campbell joined by Ken Coleman this hour
I know we get a lot of new listeners
this time of year and so if you're a new
listener and you're going what is all
this stuff they keep mentioning baby
step 3B and 4 and 7 what is all this
about well we made an incredible tool
for you at ramseysolutions.com you can
click on the get started button and we
will help you figure out the best next
step for you based on your specific
situation we'll give you all the tools
and resources we can to help you along
this journey all right so before the
break we were talking to Mitch in
Atlanta here's the situation he's in
baby step seven he's got a paid for home
or 300 Grand he's got 23 000 in savings
6 000 in checking
and he's been a real estate agent for 25
years but has not done any investing and
he's trying to figure out what is next
Mitch welcome back you still with us you
just nailed it yeah good good summary
skills okay yes so you said your parents
have a bunch of property they have about
13 properties that you would inherit
solely
uh be me my brother my sister so we're
probably looking about maybe 600
thousand each probably worth a property
do you think they would want to sell it
or do they want to keep it and use the
cash flow as income uh we've been
they've been talking about selling and
they've sold one they bought another one
they just buy and sell and I don't know
that you know they're 80 and 83 years
old and they just don't want to stop
working uh they're both really in really
good shape
um they live close to Nashville too so
I'm I'm that's close to my hometown cool
um
you know I just don't so let's find a
plan for Mitch aside from whatever
happens later down the line I want to
make sure that you know what to do in
the next 5 10 15 years
yes so on one side financially we've got
to get you investing you're at a great
place to do it because you have no debt
including a mortgage payment and so
there's a lot of options for real estate
agents number one you can look into IRAs
Roth IRA is going to be a great option
for you and you can look into are you
self-employed no employees
self-employed okay you can also look
into a SEP IRA which is for
self-employed folks that have no
employees and you can contribute up to
25 of your income which is incredible
comparatively to a lot of other
investing options
okay so those are two options right off
the bat that I can think of solo 401ks
are also an option I would connect with
a smartvester pro at ramseysolutions.com
who can walk you through all of the
options for your specific situation
do I look pretty good on paper with my
age and no debt I mean yeah where do I
stand well you need more income as far
as retiring tomorrow you'd have nothing
to live off of and so that's the only
concern you're in a great spot
financially compared to the rest of
America and so the goal right now is to
get you a little Nest Egg to create some
cash flow so that when you want to
retire 10 years from now and not have to
work you're able to do that
so a second job is what I need to do I
think well I'm going to push you on that
I don't know if you need a second job I
think you need either to do better in
your job or get a better job and I'm not
in any way uh criticizing you but I
lived in the Atlanta area for 11 years
and a real estate agent who's only
making fifty thousand dollars a year in
the Atlanta area
either
doesn't want to make much more than that
or doesn't really like it and there's
something that's kind of holding you
back from really getting after it how
many homes do you sell in 2020 hold on
hold on a sec I want to get that answer
there what so I just nailed it what did
I need yeah because I'm I've done it for
25 years and and
you know I people are just not the same
as they used to be and you know dealing
with the public people were just mean
they're just mean people out there and
I'm just having to deal a hard time
dealing with people's attitudes and
everything else
okay so that's what's keeping you from
getting after it you just you have a
there's not much to encourage you to get
out there and kill something and drag it
home
correct okay correct all right so that's
because you're not really wired for this
I don't know that people are any more
rude or or than they were 20 years ago
it's a tough business to get out there
and put yourself out there because it's
got a lot of rejection associated with
it if you don't get people listening
with you uh or people uh you know buying
from you and and I just I think you're
in the wrong business
car's my passion uh real estate used to
be my fashion what do you need when you
say cars are your passion what do you
mean flipping them renovating them
mechanics what are we talking about I
have a car I have a car Channel on
YouTube and and I just love finding cars
and saving them from being crushed or
whatever what do you do with them when
you save them
well I've helped people I found how
people will call me and I have tried to
you know find cars for people and I've
done that a lot lately but I don't make
any really money off that but I just
like buying these okay especially
Jaguars and Trans Ams I just love these
cars and I want to save as much as I can
and me saving a car all right so while I
love that I love that we're beginning to
see something that fires you up okay so
you love restoration renovation that
there's something there so you need to
get into that type of business you've
got to be making money
and real estate I mean again you can get
over this and kind of bite the bullet
and start getting more active and I
would recommend that for the next
however many months it's going to take
for you to get clear on what it is you
really want to do and what you may have
to do to get qualified to do it but if
you just started like flipping cars and
getting serious about it you may have to
sell a house or two and take some of
that commission and put it towards now
I'm gonna go buy a car I'm going to buy
a car for five or six grand that was
about three to six grand of work I can
sell it for 20. all right
the profit you just said exactly what
I'm wanting to do then do it do it
because here's the deal you should be
highly motivated right now because
you're not making enough money
Mitch you should be making six figures
or more
but but to get you to six figures is all
about getting serious and and I think
you've got a highly highly motivated
cause right now which is I need to get
busy
funding my retirement I've done some
good things I've lived on less than I
make I have no debt that's all great but
now it's about income you need to do
something that makes your heart swell
brother
not free
you're right
what's going on you're right I know
where's this emotion coming from what's
going on this I'm just tired I'm just
tired of uh
just tired of getting out there and
doing the best I can but I keep getting
you know it just don't seem to be
working out it's not working more it's
not working out because it's actually
not your best and it's not because
you're lazy
it's because you got yourself into a
role that's just not a good fit for you
it's why I teach we are on purpose Mitch
well you're doing what we were born to
do when we use what we do best that's
talent to do something we love that's
passion to produce results that matter
to us and you've never had that
what were you doing when you were on
fire
I was well I was really loving when I
did that the thing I love to do is find
homes for people that needed a home
I I love being a part of their new
adventure in the new life
well something changed so we don't need
to recycle what we've talked about so
far but you can re-gather that maybe you
should start looking for the people that
really need the extra help people that
are looking for a house that they don't
know where to find it maybe it's lower
income or maybe it's but you need to get
some juice man and and you think about
the cars and all of that but start doing
something that you love that you look
forward to when you get out of bed not
something you're worried about dealing
with and that's what's going on that's
why you're exhausted to the point of
emotional
you're you're nailing it right on the
head everything you're saying is exactly
what I thought actually I knew it I just
need to hear it you needed to push you
need it yeah you needed to push there is
work that you were put on this planet to
do and there are people on the other
side of that orc Mitch
you need to reconnect with your heart
and work that fires you up because you
look forward to it you enjoy it
and it produces a result
that gives you satisfaction and
significance George I love this there's
the the he's literally emotionally
drained well because it's been so long
he thinks it's too late that but it's
been so long
since he got up and finished a day of
work where he felt good about himself
that's a heavy weight absolutely hey
Mitch I want to send you Ken's book from
paycheck to purpose as well as his get
clear career assessment I think those
two resources are going to help you step
into this next chapter of your life call
it an encore career but you're not done
Mitch you know a lot of contribution to
make in this world and I'm excited to
see you step into that with no debt what
a great place to start thank you for the
call brother this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
this is the Ramsey Show I'm George
Campbell joined by Ken Coleman this hour
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five you jump in let's
talk about your career your work your
purpose your life your money we are here
for you now can we just talk to a guy
named Mitch and it was more of a purpose
call than a financial call and I gifted
him to get clear career assessment we
didn't have time to get into what that
even is but it's such a helpful tool for
folks like Mitch who are going what I'm
doing it ain't it and I'm not sure what
the next thing is yeah so what is the
get clear assessment it is a 20-minute
or less assessment 15 to 20 minutes we
do the hard work by asking you specific
questions that will give you answers
that reveal to you what you do best
think of your talent your strengths as
tools so you get a detailed report on
your top talents then you get a detailed
report on your top passions you use the
word passion in this assessment to
describe work you love to do you look
forward to it and when you're in the
middle of it time seems to disappear and
then the final report you'll get in the
assessment is
um your top missional result in other
words what motivates you what results do
you want to put into the world and so
then we put it all together in a purpose
statement that allow you to have a high
level job description of essentially
what is your sweet spot this role that
you were created to fill and here's the
good news it'll lead to many different
career paths could be many different
types of jobs but in one purpose
statement and then the Deep dive of the
report that you get you're going to be
able to know what you do best what you
love to do and what results matter to
you and it becomes essentially Georgia
30 000 foot View
of the world at work for you that would
give you meaning and allow you to make
money so it's a great resource you can
get it at ramsesolutions.com it's called
the get clear
career assessment and it will give you
Clarity and here's what I know George
when a person is clear they are
confident and when a person is confident
they can be courageous when life throws
things at them whether they're trying to
win financially win relationally or
professionally so that's why we created
it it's a wonderful gift to someone
maybe that kid who's getting ready to
graduate this year it's worked for it
works for students college students
husbands that are stuck wives that are
feeling like oh I want to come back into
the workforce maybe what would I do it's
a wonderful application so check it out
the get clear career assessment at
ramseysolutions.com love it all right
let's get to the phones Robert awaits Us
in my hometown of Boston Massachusetts
Robert welcome to the show
Hi how are you guys we are doing great
how can we help
oh thanks for taking my call
um so I'm 23 years old and I just paid
off my student loans in one year which
is twenty seven thousand dollars way to
go
thank you thank you uh so I have an I.T
job right now I'm making 70 000 a year
and with that I get a 401k and a four
percent company match so I put 10 in
right now
um and I think that's looking pretty
good uh so I live at home with my
parents friend free right now and I pay
all my expenses and I have no debt other
than uh at all actually
um so I'm thinking of doing house
hacking it's to move out eventually in a
couple years and I was wondering how I
should get started with that and what do
you guys think I need to save for that
how much do you have in savings right
now
um I have about 10 grand left over after
paying all my student loans and stuff
okay so let's call that your emergency
fund
yeah okay and you're investing 10 what
does the company match
four percent
well if you're following the baby steps
are you a new listener to the plan
uh relatively okay so you would be a we
call baby step four which is invest 15
of your income into retirement so if I'm
in your shoes I'm bumping that up at 23
years old with no debt and some money in
the bank you're in such an incredible
financial position
and you're wondering well where does
home ownership fall into this well that
would be baby step 3B is what we call
that saving up for that down payment on
a house and you can do this your own way
when it comes to three being four some
people like to invest all fifteen
percent and keep saving for the down
payment some people bring their
investing down to nothing to save for
that down payment more aggressively so
in your shoes you're young you could do
that in order to create some more margin
but I wouldn't touch that ten thousand
let's call that savings for emergencies
so now the next goal is how much is the
house that you are looking to buy this
duplex
um I haven't found anyone in particular
but I'm thinking around 200 000 to 400
000 that'd be my range have you actually
found duplexes for sale in the Boston
area in that range
um like ones that need Renovations and I
mean they're fixer-uppers
it doesn't sound like you're gonna have
money for renovations
um
because your plan is I'm gonna live on
one side and the renter is going to live
in the other and they're going to
magically pay my mortgage is that the
idea
yeah what are the values of duplexes in
these areas I mean do they hold their
value
typically because in the Boston area
that's very hard to get housing okay I
imagine there's people uh duplexes are
in high demand because of this idea that
you're talking about so I don't know
that you're going to find a deal on a
duplex unless it needs a lot of
Renovations and man at 23 with no money
that is a dangerous scenario because
what happens when the tenant doesn't pay
on time oh and by the way they live next
door and so anytime something happens
they're knocking on your door because
they know the landlord lives next door
oh that's awful and so I would just
tread with caution I know this is big
advice on tick tock on the financial
side of hey just house hack it's so easy
you can make so much money but man it is
so much more complicated than that and
it can be very risky is that what house
hacking is I I wasn't gonna ask but now
I don't care that's the idea I don't
know what Robert did I sum it up well as
to what house hacking yeah so yeah okay
you get a duplex you know three fan four
family and you live in one unit and you
rent out the other ones which then
ideally pays for your mortgage and then
some to you want to live with your
renters that's a really boy you you
ought to do that on the talk George
because I think that would get some
views nobody wants my opinion there
because they're all wanting to make
money Ken they don't want to hear it but
they're not thinking about living next
door to their renters and when something
goes wrong guess what
absolutely and what happens if you don't
get back to them fast enough and they
got anger issues well when the HVAC goes
I could go on and it's on you to fix and
you to pay for it and so that will
that's what worries me Robert is it
sounds like you're looking to put as
little down to get into this thing as
possible on a 30-year in order to get
the renter to pay the other side
yeah and so our housing advice is a
15-year fixed rate mortgage because we
want you in debt for as little time as
possible and where the with the payment
is no more than a quarter of your
take-home pay and so if you can do that
and without having a tenant involved
then I would say you're financially
ready to to get that duplex or buy a
house
and that might mean you need to save up
you know 40 as a down payment instead of
five percent in order to make those
numbers work but it's it's not to be you
know super fundamental and go you're
doing it wrong if you don't do it this
way it's because of risk yeah and all
you see on paper is upside if you can
just do the crunch the numbers but
reality is a whole lot different so
Robert let me just let me flip this if
you knew that you could buy a home that
only you lived in
and you could pay it off quickly
and then reap the benefits of that very
Sound Investment much later in life
would you choose that or the housing
hack idea
well I was always thinking that I could
use the housing hack idea as an
investment in the future where when I'm
even on 30 I can move out of that and
have those two being rented and then buy
a house after that but I do like the
idea of maybe being able to pay off my
own house a lot quicker yeah then buy
another then buy another house but the
point is you skip the whole idea where
you're a landlord
yeah you don't want to be a landlord you
just want to make money wisely that's
what I heard yeah am I correct
yeah I agree with that yeah so maybe we
we start looking at hey let's get a
condo for Robert that he can live in
maybe you want to get a roommate maybe
get a two bedroom condo and you can get
a roommate uh but I wouldn't go
investing in real estate until you've
got a paid for house yourself and you're
at a different place financially and
there's no rush man you're 23. who cares
if you get into this at 33 or 43.
everyone feels like I'm too late Ken if
I don't get into it but everyone there's
an 18 year old on Tick Tock who got
started and now he's making millions man
I think we got to get off I got a phrase
for you stop with the housing hacks stay
with the housing facts wow huh Robert
are you gonna tweet that nothing says
middle-aged man like that yeah they
don't like that on the talk no one likes
that yeah but it's a fact it's true well
it is yeah Robert I hope I hope that
helps I know I don't want to stomp on
your uh your parade there
and rain on it but I've just seen too
many situations where it doesn't go
according to plan like it did on paper
and The Tick Tock said it was going to
be easy and it would always work out and
life is just messy man so the best thing
you can do is walk into this thing with
patience with wisdom and with more money
than you think you need because it's
expensive speaking of life hacks I got
one for you folks all you youngsters out
there I still haven't met anybody that
got rich off of tick-tock advice oh that
hurt people's feelings Scandal I'm sure
they're watching us oh boy well hey that
puts this hour of the Ramsey Show in the
books my thanks to Ken Coleman uh and
all the folks in the booth keeping the
show alive and you America thank you for
listening we will be back real soon
foreign
hey George camel here if you love the
show and you want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we've got a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you helpful
articles and tips on following the
Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
the newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm your host George Campbell
Join This Hour by my good friend Ken
Coleman and we're taking your calls
about life money work purpose career you
name it at this number triple eight
eight two five five two two five Jaren
kicks us off in St Louis Jaren welcome
to the show
thanks for having me absolutely how can
Ken and I help
well I've been do we've been trying me
and my wife have been trying to do this
uh baby step thing this is the third
time now we're doing it we've been bet
free two other times but we're having
trouble this time with
condensing all of our money that we're
making all our excess money and putting
it all toward their debts because now
that we've got some extra cash we know
that we can obviously here and there
nickel and dime oh so to hear maybe
you're sort of there and we can't just
keep to the budget at all
so you said you've become debt free two
times but you keep going back into debt
yeah we didn't do it the hard way we did
it the easy way with income taxes on a
tax returns is how God that's paid off
but now we're in a bigger debt snowball
how much debt do you have now we know we
have
uh I don't remember total here and there
but I know like
Otto we have
um 28 000 for one vehicle 86 for another
vehicle a personal loan at 54 and then
another personal loan at probably about
22 000 for what what are these loans for
well the two vehicles we have and then
um one personal loans our AC and our
furnace went out over the summer so we
had to get a new one and then the 22 000
personal loan was for my mom for helping
us out when last year when I got laid
off from the whole covid thing and so
she helped us keep our house and
everything else so we just eventually
owe her somebody that obviously doesn't
collect interest but what's your income
our household
um take home is about 5 000 give or take
a couple hundred you both working
yes she works part-time I work full-time
so you guys are making 60k
yes roughly and you have a hundred and
ten thousand dollars in car loans
no no no no no no no no two personal
loans in addition to the you said 28 on
one vehicle and 86 on another you mean 8
600. no yeah eighty six hundred dollars
you scared me to death Jeremy yeah oh my
goodness there's no freaking way had an
aneurysm okay we're good well you say no
freaking way like we might be a little
nervous you got uh best I could tell
close to 70 grand or not more in
personal loans
I would die well well you've got you're
drowning 37 in car loans and you got
another 76 in personal loans
yeah so we're talking we're talking 110
total in Consumer Debt
making 60k and we're not able to stick
to a budget is that both of you equally
this is not coming down to you wanting
to buy a soda these are big decisions
you guys have made
yeah
um
yeah she she's we've been trying to pay
off our debts for the past couple years
but
it's just my income was studying we
weren't making any like any extra but
now that I doubled my income this year
what's your income we've got all those
extra my income now I bring home about 4
000 a month instead of the 2000 a month
I was bringing home what do you do
I'm a truck driver
how long you've been doing that for
uh uh off and on since 2014 I think it
is but I just got back into the business
uh in November because I can listen to
your show and focus are you over the
road
no I'm home every night okay yeah I was
gonna say what's your opportunity I'm
just growth there yeah being in the
business eight years can you go make
more as a truck driver elsewhere
no not really not in my area
are you sure about that because I just I
mean I just this off the top of my head
I always see huge bonuses companies are
desperate for drivers these days I'll
give you an idea what George is talking
about I shared an article on the Ken
Coleman show not too long ago uh about
Walmart hiring in the 110 000 range for
drivers
oh yeah they say they're hiring for that
but I've applied everywhere but since I
haven't actually driven over the road in
the past year year and a half they say
that I can't drive for them so they
don't want me so so what do you need to
do in order to be qualified
drive over the road what I'm doing for
about a year and a half okay well you
need to get busy then uh when you're not
driving you need to be uh working uh
extra hours another 30 hours minimal
you've got to bring in some more income
right now and your wife needs to think
about full-time job if not for very long
but just a short season to get some
momentum here what's the car worth the
one that has 28 000 left on it
uh well we got it for
26 and then after tax sales tax and
everything's 28 but it's worth 28. okay
how much money do you guys have in the
bank
uh we have a thousand in our emergency
fund and then yeah we have about five
we've done big step along with two
thousand dollars and then we're just and
we've already paid off our first debt
which was a medical bill and that's all
we've got right now okay I wonder if we
stack up cash to buy a beater car and we
sell this car and we clear 28 grand just
like that
okay yeah the only reason I got it was
so that I could get out of the house to
get to work in case it snows you can get
out of the house with a beater car they
go the same places as 28 000 cars turns
out
and they're out there five thousand
dollar car you sell it what's your car
payment on that 28
uh uh 429 a month imagine if you had
that back in your budget to then put on
other debts how much quickly you begin
to pay stuff off you got it
yes sir sell the car
it's got to go right now it's a lot of
Your World tied up in cars
yeah and so I figured since it was since
it was since both payments were almost
were about half of my yearly net
take-home the payment doesn't matter
they'll get you on 100 payment they
don't care they'll just stretch it out
until you die
at eight percent interest
they don't give a rip and uh I care
about the balance because that's what
it's going to take to get this payment
out of your life and so that's what you
got to do man and as far as the budget
goes I'll gift you every dollar premium
which will connect to your bank it'll
make it easier to track all those
transactions there's a paycheck planning
tool in there where it'll show you
exactly when your bills are due when you
would run out of money it helps you
figure out what I need to move around in
order to do this but jiren has to be a
part of this and your spouse has to be a
part of this going we are not going to
spend money that is not reflected in the
budget and if we go over that's it once
the money's out it's out and cash
envelopes are a great way to do this
Sharon where you say all right 300 bucks
for groceries we're gonna get 300 in
cash from the ATM and put it in an
envelope once the 300 is gone it's out
and we've got to figure something out
but that's part of the reason people are
successful with the budget is because
they treat it like gospel this is what
we planned this is we're gonna set out
to do and we did it you've got to track
every dollar no more random stops no
more eating out we gotta clean up this
six figure mess and it's gonna take
spending less and making more and if you
do both of those things you can become
debt free within a few years my friend
hang on the line Austin's gonna pick up
we will gift you one year of every
dollar premium call us back if we can
help along the way this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
foreign
we were drawn to Christian Healthcare
Ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
Health Care coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the Better Business Bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business check us out at
chministries.org backslash budget we
absolutely believe in it
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined by Ken Coleman
this hour
so many of you are asking this year
Building Wealth in this economy in 2023
can it be done we keep hearing that
question we get your confusion there's
so much noise out there right now with
inflation and layoffs and interest rates
and you deserve answers and we are
coming to a city near you with the
Building Wealth live event tour Dave
Ramsey and all of us Ramsey
personalities will be hitting the road
this spring to see you live in person
and at each event we're going to dig
into all of these hot topics and give
you a proven plan to build wealth and
keep it even in this economy
tickets are moving fast so if you've
been thinking about joining us don't
miss your chance we are coming to
Indianapolis February 16th Austin Texas
on February the 23rd Salt Lake City on
April the 24th and Anaheim California on
May 2nd tickets start at just 49 bucks
or you can get a four pack of tickets
starting at 175. bring some friends
bring some family it's going to be a
good time ramseysolutions.com events is
the place to go to reserve your seats
today what's up Austin what's up Anaheim
uh me and Dr John deloney will be out on
that trip so and Rachel Cruz and I our
team Indianapolis and Salt Lake City so
in case you're wondering let's get more
support in those two cities so that we
can Trash Talk it's not a competition
Ken well everybody will smoke use in a
heartbeat
I like it no I'll say that those
Millennials are snowflakes they got some
fight in them that's right we do way to
go George well I'll miss you on the road
Ken yeah we always have a good time we
do have a good time do have a good time
but those events by the way great great
Energy Great crowds and you and Dr John
do a fantastic pre-show that's kind of a
secret bonus but it's become a highlight
for me and you get a bunch of free
content and uh lots of Tears lots of
high fives lots of laughs I love it
ramseysolutions.com
events is the place to go who's up next
George let's go to uh let's go to Frank
I've been waiting in Phoenix patiently
Frank welcome to the show
are you there
oh hey thanks for taking my call guys
sorry about my phone I'm doing a Dave
Ramsey's uh thing I'm driving a beater
car applying it to a smartphone so it's
not fair enough you got a beater
smartphone what I got it's what I got
you sound you sound fantastic
well thank you I'm in a quandary and I
want your advice on this I've I'm 58
years old never financed anything in my
life
um I've got a pretty good job here and
the car that I had eight months ago
started breaking down I mean every week
was another thousand dollars getting to
the point
of my dependability at work was in
question so I ended up going to a
dealership and getting into the most
horrible deal I had no idea what I
understood is that I was buying a
fifteen thousand dollar car at 24
interest for 1980. I agree to that they
said I can make payments early to pay
off the principal and I just work like
it unlike a gazelle right and pay it off
well that's not the case it turns out I
called the finance company about double
three days after taking possession of
the car it is enormous Reynolds I said
Frank you uh you owe thirty thousand
dollars not nineteen thousand dollars
and I'm like wait a minute I didn't
agree to this well here's where we're at
so for seven months I've been making
payments every month never been late
the total hasn't come down at all and
I'm going nowhere and killing myself on
this the warranty expired
you know the dealers uh seven year
hundred thousand that's gone because of
the year now my father has offered the
loan me twenty thousand dollars for the
buyout price of nineteen eight or
whatever it is and he's probably going
to charge me six percent simple interest
and well that would mean that I'm gonna
end up paying 27 when I Blue Book the
car it came up to ten thousand dollars
not the 15 that they claimed so I would
end up paying 27 000 on a ten thousand
dollar car without a warranty now what
I'm thinking is offering them thirteen
thousand tell them to apply to seven
I've already spent and see if they'll
take it if not give them the car back I
don't know if any of it works like that
Frank what Incarnation did you make a
deal with the devil what dealership was
this I might call about myself you are
the spawn of Satan that they really are
that this is you know the thing is a
week later when I talked to them the guy
even told me he knew I didn't know what
I was doing you know like dude you got
raked over the coals how do you even get
a car loan for 24 interest
well how is that legal I've never
well very
you know I had a roommate that was an
attorney at once and there's three parts
to a contract and one is what a
reasonable person would expect from a
deal and the meeting of the Mind we've
got neither one of them no boy here's
what I'm looking at what's your income
Frank how do we get out of this mess I
signed it I signed it you know it's not
a bad car don't get me wrong look Frank
okay Frank let's start we gotta start
breaking this thing down okay uh what
what is your income George asked you
gosh it it depends uh I'm hourly and
depending like this year we've been
rained out a lot look at about 55. what
do you do
oh this must be the day of the trucker
because I do in a local trucker okay all
right local trucker hourly wage and
you're making about 55 000 a year
that's right do you have any other debt
ah there's depending on
the IRS I may owe them about 4 000 but
that may be absorbed through this last
tax season I've gotta look how that so
you may owe some IRS back taxes
well yeah we've been from 2019 but they
only claimed one dependent this year
myself so I should have a refund it will
go do that debt okay that might be wiped
out other than that you have no debt no
credit card debt no personal loans out
there just this car I have a credit card
but that's only for emergencies
there is no emergency where your money
isn't good and so the goal is for you to
cover it it got me to work because you
know what's going to happen you're going
to get charged 24 interest from the
credit card company as soon as you don't
play their game perfectly
oh I don't use their I honestly I'm 57
I've never used credit in my life then
cut it out I don't use that card you
haven't needed it for 58 years you don't
need it now all right we got to get rid
of this car so what is the car worth I
want out of this have you done good
homework on what the car is actually
worth today uh 10 10 5. and you owe what
there were so many numbers flying around
what what do you oh what is your actual
loan currently 19
or 1906 would be the buyout Okay so
this car you are underwater on
by a degree of about nine thousand
dollars right right that's right okay
how much money do you have in the bank
uh maybe the thousand dollar emergency
after the first uh with those round of
rent utilities and all that are you
single hey man yeah yes okay where is
all of your money going you make 55k
you've got the thousand dollar emergency
fund where's your monthly income going
outside of the car payment
oh honestly I am I am a zealous listener
of your program uh in fact just uh read
the book uh Total Money Makeover a lot
of it went to repairs in the previous
car you add in rent of well it's 12.50 a
month Frank do you think you could go to
a credit union today and get a 9 000
loan
I don't think so I've never applied for
a loan okay um here's the way out of
this I'm not going to go into debt with
Dad at six percent and move this money
around here's the best plan you need to
save up and get a beater car you need to
borrow one from a friend if you've got a
local Church community see how cheaply
you can get a reliable car and save up
to that amount I have I own a car
outright okay you have another car hey
what's that car doing where is that car
whole reason I got into this is because
Frank everything where's the other car
oh sir sir let's let me explain we don't
have we got 30 seconds we got a
commercial we got to get to
I got you use the other car sell the car
today not Dependable it doesn't matter
we'll sell that one and get some of that
is Dependable but going 30 grand into
debt at 24 interest is not the path out
of this thing so you need to go to the
credit union get the difference you need
to pay that loan off to sell the car and
drive that beater until you're out of
this mess
whoo that was an entertaining doozy Ken
love talking to Frank but man I need a I
need a break I'll get you some Tums
[Music]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and netsuite's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsay today okay
and set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the Ramsay show open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five you know Ken uh usually I come with
the videos to react to but apparently
you've got one for me I have not seen
this I don't know anything about it yeah
I've got a I've got a video off the talk
I shortened Tick Tock to say talk that
somehow made it worse yeah well it
irritates my teenagers as well so I
bring that to you because I know you're
equally irritated but yeah anything you
need to tell me about this video no uh
well this is a this is a video that went
viral and this is
um this is a warning video
and um I got I shared this on the Ken
Coleman show earlier today and this this
could be relevant for a lot of our
listeners and viewers so let's play it
then we'll comment on
a day in my life getting laid off at
Google so I woke up to this really
ominous text from my boss and I honestly
had no idea what it was going to be
about so I called her the minute I woke
up and saw this and she told me to check
the news and my email so I rushed
downstairs to find out that I had lost
access to basically everything I
couldn't log into my email or even check
my calendar I called my boss back and we
just sobbed over the phone because she
was also finding out about my layoff for
the first time today too I started
getting calls from a bunch of my
co-workers and started finding out who
else was let go on my team and some
neighboring teams as well but I think
the worst part is that it seems like no
one was consulted on this decision and
everyone was just finding out about the
layoffs at the same time it just felt
like a really bad game of Russian
Roulette and there was no consistency
around who was let go it was also not
Performance Based so it just felt really
random okay so there you go now in the
news it came out on Friday of last week
George Google laid off about 12 000
employees which is about six percent of
their Global Workforce this is across
the product areas functions different
product areas functions levels and
regions according to CEO Sundar pakai if
you say it that way I think it is I
think I'm Hooked on Phonics uh that this
is a result of Google hiring too quickly
and couldn't keep all its staff on the
current economic reality but here's why
I showed that video on the Ken Coleman
show why we show it here George
anytime that you hear a talk of
recession and we're seeing a larger
companies laying off people more
announced more expected to be announced
this week a lot of tech companies laying
people off and this is happening more
and more
this is a young lady
who finds out about the layoffs when she
sees the news and she wakes up she calls
her direct leader who says well let's
get online and figure this out together
I don't know if if you've been laid off
or not she goes downstairs to get on her
laptop and is subsequently locked out
she finds out I've been locked out
overnight and so her her direct leader
did not even know that this young lady
had been laid off now man how does that
hit you well from what I read I saw a
piece that was saying hey folks didn't
know if they didn't check their email
the night before they showed up to work
and there was just a line of people
checking their fobs and that's how you
figure out that's how you found you can
get in the door you're still employed no
that's a terrible way to go about it now
folks the reason we share this is if you
were at a company I don't care how large
or small and you don't have a sense
that the leadership values you as an
individual not a unit of production then
you need to start paying attention
because leaders like this and this is
Google and they think they're too big
for it to really have a negative impact
on them but I'm going to tell you
something they aren't too big to fall
and this has been a wave of just social
media testimonies about them doing this
I've got a Business Insider article
right here in my hands
and one engineer shares a story of being
at Google for 20 years
an engineer for 20 years and he was laid
off via email
no face-to-face conversation here's a
couple more
this is this is the worst
uh another guy
um
says that he went in
at 4am
this is Dan Russell research scientist
said on LinkedIn I found out when I went
to work at 4am to finish up an important
analysis and my badge didn't work
the guy's going at 4am to work and his
badge doesn't work 17 and a half years
at Google gone Elizabeth Hart a senior
Marketing Manager on Google's Global ads
team
uh said she woke up early Friday morning
and saw a notification
that her corporate access had expired
along with an email with the New York
Times link to the article about Google
laying people off oh man so Google is
big enough Savvy enough to know that
they're gonna have to lay people off
there's no excuse
for not having a real person sit down
with them eyeballed eyeball knee to knee
and explain what's going on and have
some sense of compassion but let me tell
you what it is George it's about a
checklist we got to lay off 12 percent
of our uh 12 000 people six percent of
our Workforce we don't have time to do
it this way this is how we're going to
do it and you know what we're Google
we'll just get another batch of young
people coming out of college and and I'm
going to tell you something this is
eventually going to catch up to
companies well you lose the guy who had
20 years experience and you hire the guy
who's just jumping into this thing well
you make a very good point not only do
you lose him you treat him so harshly
that he leaves with a bunch of
institutional knowledge that you don't
even know what he's what he knows and
what he's taking with him it's bad
business forget bad human behavior it's
bad business Behavior so all that to say
well in these publicly traded companies
can
a lot of them are just beholden to the
shareholders that's 100 stock price
whatever they got to do to make the
shareholders happy and therefore people
become a unit of production which is sad
so you want to know why there's an
anti-work movement why is that this kind
of nonsense
you treat people like they aren't humans
you treat them like they are just a
number on your spreadsheet they start to
believe that
you know like quiet quitting is a
phenomenon because of crap like this
leaders not valuing people
and when you would just keep treating
people like units of production you
don't care for them you don't treat them
like they've got a heart uh like they've
like they've got emotions then uh you're
gonna have a revolt and this just
continues to happen so we're going to
shine the light on here at Ramsey
Solutions because
we care about people here we care about
our team we care about you and you can
work in a place that values you you
better get to one of those places
because I'm telling you if you're not in
a place that values people even if they
have to lay you off
okay uh in a place where they care about
you they'll treat you well that's true
and thankfully Ramsay has never had to
lay anyone off in the history of this
place which is pretty amazing and it
speaks to how much they value people so
just bad behavior so can a lot of people
I see on their LinkedIn it says you know
hashtag open to work what do people do
in a case where they were just laid off
or they could potentially be laid off
any minute what would you suggest they
do on the career side okay well first
thing is this is a this is a really
rough rejection so you need to grieve
this you don't understand that while it
may not be personal it feels personal so
let's let's go get it out of our system
friends family members if you gotta cry
some fine you know the point is let's
own it that it sucks that it hurts and
then after we've gotten that out of our
system that it feels that way we've got
to then step back into reality that it
does not hurt your future a lot of
people have been laid off people get
laid off all the time
and there's still a lot of opportunities
and so you get back up on the horse and
the way you do that is I'm going to make
connections connections connection
connections I hope that you have
connections laid out way in advance you
know when you get on an airplane and the
flight attendants come in and they tell
you in case of a water landing here are
your exits you need to do the same thing
if you work for a large company if you
work for a company that may be
struggling financially you don't know
what could happen so what would an exit
strategy look like if a storm came you
know I could see you in your new home I
bet you have a storm shelter and so you
got your flashlight you got your
batteries you got your water I'm going
to John eloni's house if something goes
down that's not a good idea because he's
just going to put you with the chickens
that's true but the idea is okay who are
people that I know in my industry that
are really well connected
um what is a part-time or an Uber type
job that I could take on or two
part-time job you might have to swallow
your pride and go what do I need to do
right now to bring it in well this gets
back to George you and what Dave and
Rachel teach about the budget if I know
my four walls budget then what are some
jobs that I know that I could probably
go get pretty quickly that take care of
my four walls that's what I mean by
having an extra strategy that's
temporary
until maybe I can then get back into the
industry that I want to be in that's the
idea it doesn't have to be a crisis we
want it to be a nuisance big difference
I like that so the emergency fund yeah
being debt free and having money in the
bank it changes a layoff drastically
yeah oh yeah because now it's annoying
and frustrating but it's not devastating
so man uh really pulling for all those
folks that are getting laid off around
the nation and it's a wild time we are
hoping the best for you you can jump
into a new career and Ken's advice is
spot on this is not the end this does
not define you it will refine you if you
let it this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell Join This Hour by Ken
Coleman hey if you like this show
there's only one thing I would ask of
you again the show is free and what I'm
asking you to do is free consider
subscribing leaving a review wherever
you're listening and sharing this show
with a friend we want to spread the
impact and affect more people this year
with our money message our career
message mental health relationships
there's so many problems out there in
the world and we want to help solve them
and this show is a part of that and the
way you do that is you share it with
friends who need to hear it and Word of
Mouth goes a long way I appreciate you
doing that thank you and by the way who
doesn't like this show I don't know why
they're listening I'm unaware of this
strange to waste your time listening to
a show you don't like goodness gracious
speaking of things you like or don't
like what do you think about my sweater
today George uh I'm a fan I like it the
chunky Donegal look Ken
now I regret asking you I don't know
what any of that means well we'll get
you there just Google it okay let's go
to Shannon up next in Austin Texas
Shannon how are you doing
I'm great thanks so much for taking my
call absolutely
okay so I have career changing uh
questions
um about three years ago right before
covid I retired from over 30 years in
education I've been a teacher a
principal even a director
um at like the central office level and
I left that job because it just wasn't a
good situation but I left it for another
job I was able to retire so I had my
retirement my pension income and I left
to be a director at a day school which
because of covet ended up closing in
early 21
so since then I have just kind of been
working a couple of part-time jobs
um plus I have I have about 5 400 a
month coming in from my pension
um but I feel like I need to be doing
something else when I retired I was only
54. I'm 57 I'll be 58 this year
um
so I've had time since like 21 about a
year and a half to just kind of be in
this kind of flux State
um but I'm not really sure what I want
to do next yeah I don't know if I you
know the easy thing is yes go back to
education
um but I really am not really sure what
I want to do next all right so let me
ask you when when you really loved it
when when teaching was good
what did you love most about it
making a connection with the kids and
then as a principal making a connection
with the staff and the teachers and just
being able to
positively bring about change nice and
what kind of change so I understand the
connection part you would do that
through communication and instruction
but the change that most excited you
describe that just a little bit more
um just being able to help somebody get
from a place where they weren't
able to read or to understand something
and then they were able to do that or to
help a teacher you know uh develop their
skill sets so they were even a better
teacher or bringing staff together so
that they were developing their own
leadership and you know okay that kind
of thing all right that's beautiful so
this is my this is what I heard
okay the change that most motivates you
that gives you the juice as I like to
say is where you take someone from where
they are
to where they want to be whether it's a
kid struggling with math
whether yeah I mean that's your jam
am I right okay yes all right so
I think that you do that through
instruction
or you do that through leadership and
I'm talking functionally
okay right so when we look at potential
jobs and positions
for you it comes down to you've got to
be in the role of instructor
leader
um advisor
and these aren't job titles I'm just
talking about a role because you're
spending most of you if you're spending
most of your day doing that that's a
good day for you true or false
yes very true yeah so that's what you're
looking for but it does not have to be
in a traditional educational environment
I mean if you look at the world at work
right now you're wildly qualified
to be a trainer but I guess yes and I
just I don't know how to make that leap
and I I'm sure you do kind of like a
little confidence that's what's going on
that's what's going on it's not that you
don't know how to make the leap it's
that you doubt that anyone's gonna give
you a chance
in a different field because that's all
you've ever done is education
right I know
so
how do we overcome that doubt
we've got to start having conversations
we got to make connections to people who
see you as a very experienced educator a
woman who has 30 years of pouring into
the lives of others
and on the other side of that
delivering influential positive change
that's your MO
and so when you start believing that
about yourself you're going to be more
confident have those conversations but
I'm going to give you a copy of my book
uh the first book I wrote here at Ramsey
Solutions was called the proximity
principle which says in order to do what
Shannon wants to do she's got to be
around people that are doing it and in
places where it is happening very simple
idea correct okay yes so there's five
people in five places in the book that
will kind of help you begin to visualize
and then make direct connections with
these people in Austin or around the
country if you're open to moving outside
of Austin if you're not there certainly
a lot of opportunities in Austin Texas
for a woman like you who's got heart and
who's got crazy skill and a whole lot of
experience am I right Shannon
probably yes oh Shannon I just gave that
big pep talk and I get a probably I know
I know yes there is there are things
that I could be doing rather than making
13 an hour at two exactly so here's the
deal you need to start looking at job
opportunities today that are around
training opportunities instructional
opportunities I'll give you an example
we hired someone here recently in
instructional design uh for our Ramsey
education department a lifelong teacher
on the Collegiate level or maybe High
School level but the ability to to
connect with students as we're creating
programs my point is is if it is
training if it is instruction if it is
advising if it is guiding if it is
leading you're qualified for all of that
Shannon
okay
I am I am there we go so now you know
what you're looking for we're not even
looking in the education but now listen
once we look very practically no more
pep talk
once we begin to see those jobs then you
step back and you've got my book The
Proximity principle will give to you you
step back and you go who do I know that
knows somebody in this company or who do
I know that knows somebody in this
organization or if I don't know anybody
that knows somebody who do I know that
knows somebody that knows somebody and
we begin to start to make connections
you start having conversations and then
people meet this unbelievably qualified
lady who's got a lot of horsepower and a
lot left to give and they go man we'd
love to have you over here we just need
to train you on this particular type of
training but you got all the skills all
the experience we're just going to teach
you the language you see where I'm going
here okay
you're full of doubt
you feel like you've got this imposter
syndrome because you don't know what you
don't know
that's true you know that's your problem
Shannon you know nothing
so it's big and scary am I right Shannon
right but if I was your student and I
walked in your classroom and I said
Shannon I don't know anything what would
you say to me
well let's start to see what you do know
because you do know some things you're
right and so you do know people in
Austin Texas
you do know Quality Companies you do
know now what to look for don't you
yes so then what would you say to me I'd
say okay I do know this Shannon and I
know this machine and I know this what
do I do now what would you say to me you
have to just up and do it you have
to just start reaching out to people
making the connections and having the
confidence the student becomes the
teacher look at that yeah it sounds like
you should do it and what's amazing is
that financially you're not desperate
yeah so you're not worried about what
the paycheck is right now you're looking
for what will give me the most purpose
and allow me to contribute in a way I
want to
and that opens up your options I got two
words for you Shannon these are teacher
level words I'm trying to impress you
right now picky picky and Persnickety
that's your problem those are your words
there we go all right fantastic thank
you for calling Shannon We are rooting
for you pump for you that's awesome all
right that was this hour of the Ramsay
show in the books my thanks to my
fabulous co-host Ken Coleman and all the
guys in the booth we got Austin Ben
James Zach and Andrew and you America
thank you so much for tuning in we'll be
back before you know it right here on
the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
hey it's Ken if you love the show and
want a deeper dive on your money Journey
we have a Weekly Newsletter that gives
you trending and helpful articles and
tips on following the Ramsey win go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
foreign
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm Ramsey personality George
Campbell joined by Ken Coleman this hour
the phone number to call is triple eight
eight two five five two two five this is
a show about you and your life and you
doing meaningful work and living a
debt-free lifestyle and having
incredible relationships that's what
we're here to help you do Joshua kicks
us off from New Mexico this hour Joshua
welcome to the show
yeah hi how's it going good how are you
good good okay so I I'm 24 years old um
I work in real estate my wife's a nurse
here and uh we have five investment
properties and then we have our primary
residence we have three vehicles two
still have loans on them and I guess the
Justin my question is should I sell my
investment properties to clear pretty
much all my personal debt and I think
I'd have about 40 000 left on my
personal mortgage
so how much do you have in Consumer Debt
you said you have two car loans anything
else
uh two car loans I have taxes coming up
which I actually didn't save for I
didn't do a very good job I just over
respect we bought a few investment
properties this year and we just over
invested that money
um how much are you going to own taxes
uh I'm gonna know about 47 000. whoa
that's a whole lot of not paying taxes
yeah it is how much are the car loans
uh I have about 55 on my truck and then
18 on the on my life's card
what's your household income
I total household income is probably
about 320 a year wonderful wow how much
is each car worth on the 55 truck how
much is the truck worth
that one's pretty new it might be worth
54.53 I'm I'm probably barely under
amount because I barely bought it a few
months ago okay
that one's worth about 26.
and you owe 18 on it
yeah
okay
well I would sell the cars before I
would sell the investment properties
it's a whole lot less of a hassle
okay so if you sold how much money do
you have in the bank
uh we
have total about 32 33 000. oh great
okay
so
we have to have money to pay these taxes
are they due April
yeah I'll probably file an extension
this is the first day I'll probably have
to do that and I guess that was one of
my kind of questions also would it be
smart to maybe set up a temporary
payment plan so I can pay them off this
year without having to sell
you know are you working with a tax Pro
currently
yeah okay and what has been their advice
um I I haven't got advice specifically
on this yet
um because I guess it is the first year
where I didn't do a very good job of
saving for it I would go ahead and get
this out of your life instead of kicking
the can down the road you pretty you'll
have the money once you sell these cars
and you can get two cheaper cars
okay yeah well if I did that because
they don't have a ton of equity so even
if I sold the Camry I would keep
seven eight thousand and then the truck
I wouldn't make anything probably on
that one yeah and you can just Net Zero
on that you'd have 8K plus 32k that
gives you 40K and now we still need two
cars and so we're gonna get two very
reasonable used cars they're not gonna
be fancy like the ones you have right
now but it's temporary but George I I'm
curious why you say you wouldn't sell
one at least one of the properties I you
can do that because you have do you have
a least favorite one that's giving you
the most hassle not worth the cash flow
they've all been pretty solid actually
it does pretty well on them but yeah
there's definitely some I have in mind
that I would sell before another do you
own all these cash
no no no they all have mortgages
um they all Castle pretty well and that
they can run you through the numbers if
you wanted to but they all have
mortgages on them I'd be curious so
George can get the whole picture because
I'm George I'm not sure why he's not
selling all the houses if you stand to
make money on all of them
yeah and so like I said I can let you
through kind of run through them real
quick run through so we have five houses
or four
uh five Investments and then just my
primary okay yeah run through them real
quick are we good with this George so
run through house number one
um how much do you owe on it how much
could you sell it for
okay house number one I owe about 147
and I could sell it about
255. okay number two number two IO 145 I
could tell about 235.
okay
house number three io74 I could tell at
about 110.
okay
um another one I owe 112 000 I could
tell it about 220. oh
about 212.
and just for fun your personal house how
much do you owe in your home
uh 3.95.
all right George I'm genuinely asking
well my he's got some serious uh Equity
here and he can clean all of this if
you're willing to sell one of the
investment properties it would put you
in a much better financial situation
and I might do both I might sell both
cars and sell a rental property to
really set you guys up for success
and the thing with the cars is it's a
depreciating asset
um versus the homes which are going to
appreciate at least I don't love that
you went into debt for five properties
but it's it's less risky than you know
these cars continuing to go down in
value that are toys
yeah well and my concept was that these
cars would last US 10 15 years down the
road that way we have a kid on the way
which is also why I'm trying to get
together financially and I'm going to be
more aggressive than George if it's me
I'm selling the houses I'm cleaning all
this up paying off the one you owe 112
on that's worth 220. that would clear
six figures for you yeah
yeah now you got nice paid for cars baby
on the way I I just I'd be super
aggressive the cars aren't a large part
of your world as far as income goes and
so either way something's got to give
either we sell one of those properties
to clear the car debt or we sell the
cars to clear the car debt and so so one
issue with uh and it's not a drastic
issue per se but if I were to sell a car
I would have to because I depreciated
them on my taxes so I would have to
reclaim it and you know tax money on
that
yeah but that's not a reason to stay
it's not a reason to stay in debt you're
going to have the cash to pay your taxes
you know
and you got to stay on top of it with
these taxes is your tax Pro helping you
do this
yes yeah and he's really good he's been
on it like I said this is the first year
I just we bought three investment
properties this year alone or last year
alone I guess
um and so with 25 down we we just
overspent on the investment property
yeah I pumped the brakes on the
investment Guru stuff and work on paying
these yeah off and you may just want to
snowball them and what's your mortgage
left on your primary
3.95 okay
yeah I might snowball some of the
smaller properties first and then work
on attacking that personal one and by
the end of this if you keep this up
you'll have a bunch of paid for
properties that are cash flowing no
payments in the world and a whole bunch
of money in the bank I like that plan
but with a baby on the way nothing will
get your butt in gear like a baby coming
out I'd sell them all
hey I'm a fan of Ken's move right there
it'll definitely sell every one of them
knock out as much debt as you can
eventually are going to get back into it
because you know how to do it and
whatever you have left in cash yeah you
have a few hundred thousand left over
all right let's go pay cash for some
real estate love that plan this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
this is the Ramsey Show I'm George
Campbell joined by Ken Coleman this hour
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five Jessie's up next
in Knoxville Tennessee Jesse welcome to
the show
thank you how you fellas doing we're
doing great how can we help
well uh so I'm graduating from college
in about three and a half weeks and I've
done job hunting for the last few weeks
and I'm wondering if I'm being too picky
with which jobs I take or look at oh
what is making you feel like you might
be being too picky
um
I so I've gotten a couple bites mainly
in sales positions which I'm not
particularly interested in anyway and I
just can't imagine myself doing anything
like that and not being absolutely
miserable which is the main thing I want
to avoid that sounds like some
self-awareness tell me what it is about
you that you feel like a sales job would
would just be awful what is it
um I I am a very brutally honest person
and I've in my experience at least sales
people always kind of have to be like
fakely nice or over exaggerate how good
the product is and that's just something
I wouldn't want to do and uh
what about the what about the
performance side of sales and the kind
of the pressure how's that hit you
oh well I think I'd be good at it I I
don't want to my main fear is being sort
of like my parents were where I come
home from work every day and then like
just cry myself to sleep because I'm
doing something I hate there there we go
Jesse you're my kind of guy that's why I
that's why I work is to help people find
work that they're really good at that
they love all right so what do you want
to do
I see that's the thing I'm not really
particular with what I want to do I just
don't want to do something I hate okay
so you've been in college almost four
years you're getting ready to graduate
from UT I'm guessing
uh well I'm graduating a year early but
uh okay no I'm graduating from
University of Phoenix all right oh okay
gotcha so you you said you're brutally
honest so am I I don't believe you and
I'm calling you out because I want you
to feel the confidence to tell me what
it is you're thinking about doing I
don't believe a guy like you who's as
serious as you are saying some of the
heavy things you're saying doesn't have
a couple of ideas something he's
wondered about but he's just got some
fear or he's got some doubt I don't
believe it's your mind or your heart is
a whiteboard so what are you thinking
about what's the thing that comes up all
the time come on Jesse
I I genuinely don't have one did I read
through your book and everything and the
only thing I could really come up with
was like
fatherhood or maybe game development
okay even then that's okay like super
specialized and would take forever and I
know I know excuses but yeah so you
actually answered my question and you
proved that what I said was correct you
think gaming is something that's very
interesting but it feels unattainable
for you it feels like it's not worth all
the trouble
yeah basically okay what about gaming
interest you the function of the work is
it programming coding no what is no it's
more like design figuring out how things
would work together okay so something
that let me ask you this what have you
always found that you have been able to
do pretty easily came easy for you and
people complimented you for it
um
don't overthink this probably I I'd
probably like teaching people how to do
stuff I worked in manufacturing for a
few years until I hated it I was really
good at training people
got the word for QA one time nice did
you enjoy the training part
yeah yeah I like teaching people how to
do stuff okay there's a clue
there's a clue in the fact that what
interests you about video game designing
is the design element those are all
Clues well we've got an example of is
something that you're naturally very
gifted at which is communication and
connection that's the training element
and you enjoyed the result of that
seeing somebody's light bulb come on do
it better you took some satisfaction in
that those are all Clues
and then the design element that's very
interesting maybe it's an aesthetic
maybe it's the analyzing I'm not sure
but but when you're looking for ideas on
what to do and by the way I'm going to
give you my get clear career assessment
because it's going to pull stuff out of
you but I'm going to venture to say you
overthink some stuff is that true
yeah probably yeah
I get it I'm gonna listen I'm a
recovering over analyzer myself uh but
what we want to do is we want to when
you're somebody who's overthinking
everything we want to detach the brain
and we want to go to the heart so here's
a quick exercise George can we do this
on this let's do it all right here's the
deal Jesse you got to answer quickly no
thinking you ready
yep who are the people you most want to
help what comes to mind Sam who are they
my wife your wife oh geez yeah you can't
go Hallmark on me outside of your wife
and the good husband award who are
people in this world you think I'd like
to help these people what comes to mind
when I ask the question
uh people who don't know how to handle
money people who do not handle money
fantastic all right we're going to come
at the same problem different ways
different question you ready what is the
problem or desire that they have
uh probably not knowing how to budget I
guess right maybe some discipline issues
maybe some some bad habits around money
and then finally what's the solution to
people who have money problems that you
get most excited about providing
assume their light bulb going does that
have anything to do with training or
instructing
I mean yeah yeah does it have anything
to do with maybe analyzing and designing
a plan or a program or a way to connect
to them
yep
what do you think
uh yeah I'd say so so we got something
right now here's the deal I want George
to weigh in on this too because George
has he's been around me a long time
George walked a very similar path that I
did professionally
um he gets this idea of talent what we
do best passion what we love Mission
what moves us what results motivate us
I'm going to give you the get clear
career assessment uh when we put you on
hold and my book from paycheck to
purpose that you give it to somebody
else I know you've read mine but I'm
going to give it away as a bundle but I
want you to take the assessment and then
remember this conversation that we had
because we just walked through some
Clues George any thoughts uh I'm he's
spot on right there I mean it sounds
like he's leaning towards some level of
financial coaching maybe on the side and
or certainly being an advisor a
financial advisor maybe teaching you
know a financial curriculum you know the
next step I'd go do I know anyone who'd
let me just Shadow and just pick their
brain over the coffee and see what they
do and yeah just see if that stirs you
up yeah I mean you could you could be a
smart Vester Pro down the line you know
and and train and guide people you know
you could teach on the collegiate level
he could teach on the high school level
you could go work for a company in HR
and and bring in our smart dollar
program and be the person that leads
that but there's there are some themes
here Jesse that you've got to pay
attention to and and what we just did
for people that are brand new the show
and like what was this guy doing
when you're trying to figure out what it
is you want to do with your life
professionally
don't miss that there is this emotional
component to work
love
in other words relationships and work
our occupational life they share the
same result it's about serving others
people that are happy in their work it's
not about their paycheck and uh but a
fat paycheck it makes me happy
but it's never just about that it's
about the contribution I feel like I'm
serving people I'm making a difference
in the world George well there's
something about the education system as
Jessie's talking I'm going what a broken
education system where people get out of
this whole thing after doing it for what
18 years and they're going I have no
clue yeah and so that part frustrated me
for Jesse Yeah that he spent all this
money in school got a degree and is
still walking out going no one prepared
me for what's next which tells me
there's some personal responsibility and
that the education system needs some
overhaul so now watch what happened with
Jesse this was really cool so he's
presenting on this phone call he's going
Ken I literally have no ideas at all I
knew he did but we went back a little
bit what if what always came easy for
you
like if for those of you out there that
feel like you have no idea what you want
to do you're trying to figure out begin
to look at who you are so what if people
always complimented you on doing or it
came easy for you saw somebody else
struggle in school in this thing and you
were like this is easy for me we're just
getting to I'm talented here and there's
gonna be a connection between what I do
well talent and something that I enjoy
in fact we humans George don't like to
do anything that we suck at that's true
it's only fun for a little bit and then
you go it's not fun when it's really
difficult forever I mean I see why I
don't golf that's why George doesn't
golf he's abysmal absolutely business
you at mini golf one time and I still
hold it over your head there's a back
story on that that's probably a separate
episode the front story is I beat you a
mini golf yeah it's the only story
that's all you care about hey Jesse hang
on the line we've got the get clear
career assessment which is going to get
inside your head and your heart and give
you some confidence and some clarity
love it hey more of your calls coming up
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
I'm George camel here with Ken Coleman
this is the Ramsay show we're here for
you America
well guys if you're wondering maybe uh
you're looking to buy or sell a home
this year and you're not sure about this
housing market well here's what I'll
tell you there's still more demand for
homes than there are homes to buy the
median home price is expected to keep
Rising but at a slower rate and interest
rates likely aren't going to stop going
up so what does it mean for you well if
you're buying a home you're still going
to face some competition and big price
tags and if you want to sell your home
chances are you can still make a nice
profit but you have to be patient for
the right offer to come your way and of
course this depends on where you are
every Market is going to be wildly
different and it's why you need to work
with an experienced real estate agent
when you're ready to start this home
buying or selling process you want
someone who's done this hundreds of
times before and knows how to negotiate
a strong deal based on the current
market and you can find those agents we
call them Ramsey trusted endorsed local
providers on our website these are the
top performing agents around the country
who we trust to serve you well if you
want to connect with one of those agents
just go to Ramsay Solutions dot com
slash agent that's ramseysolutions.com
agent Micah joins us up next in
Charleston South Carolina Micah welcome
to the show
hey guys how's it going we are doing
great man what's going on with you
so uh I'm uh currently here in
Charleston to uh lob station here U.S
Navy
um I'm looking at getting the rest of my
enlistment bonus gonna be about 18 Grand
and then re-enlisting in a couple of
months for anywhere between 80 to 120
120 000 uh half of which I'll get up
front and the rest in payments and
um I wanted a little bit of advice on
how to how to be smart with my money I'm
currently sitting on roughly forty
thousand dollars of combined student
loan debt and uh car debt
and
um I was thinking about paying it off
100 just getting rid of it you know
having zero debt left behind but all my
friends and everybody I know is telling
me that I shouldn't pay off my car
because I should hold on to that and uh
have it help build my credit they want
you to hold on to debt to build your
credit
yes are they making your payments on the
student loan in the car yeah then they
don't get a say
and the reason the credit score exists
is to vet people to go into debt do you
plan on going further into debt
uh the only other thing I uh plan on
taking money out for is a house a
mortgage great you can do that without a
credit score and I I tell you that with
great confidence because I did it and
it's called a no score loan through a
process called manual underwriting our
friends at Churchill Mortgage they do
these every single day and what they do
is they take a real look that's why it's
called manual and not automated
underwriting because a real person looks
at your financial picture and says hey
Mike has made on-time rent payments for
a year Mike has paid his cell phone
bills and insurance bills for a year
Micah's income to debt ratio looks great
we're going to give Micah the mortgage
it's about that simple people try to
over complicate it they try to steer you
away from it they tell you it's way more
expensive it's so difficult it's really
that simple
and so I would pay off all of this debt
and I would never look back because
again the only reason you want that
credit score is now for the mortgage
right
and we just went over why you don't need
it
yeah any other concerns about the credit
score
um not really I mean it kind of got
trashed
um about three or four years ago I
didn't know what I was doing with stuff
and I've been working it up from about
300 it's in the 600s now
okay
yeah a bad score can and will hurt you
when you go to get the mortgage so the
goal here is we're going to pay off all
of the Consumer Debt close all accounts
cut up all the credit cards close those
accounts if you have any and over a
period of time six to 12 months while
you save up your emergency fund your
down payment on the house it's going to
take you that long right a year or two
three
yeah your credit score will become
indeterminable so it probably won't go
all the way down to zero it will just
disappear eventually to where when you
go to check your score it will say
indeterminable
gotcha and by the way there's other
things people will tell you you need it
for uh like buying a car which you don't
need if you're paying cash
so save up and pay cash for used cars uh
you don't need it to rent a car and just
check the policy which with each rental
car company you might just need to have
a little buffer in your checking account
because they may add a hold if you use a
debit card
gotcha and then even renting homes I've
rented multiple homes and apartments
with no credit score
because what they're looking for is a
bad credit score to show oh this person
doesn't make payments on time no score
doesn't say that
gotcha gotcha
does that help you
yeah yeah that helps a lot okay tell
your tell your friends to go watch this
clip and maybe you guys can sit down and
listen to episode seven of the fine
print it's called the dirty truth behind
your credit score and I break all of
this down in nerdy detail I talk to
mortgage lenders I call apartments and
landlords at random all over the country
and ask them if I can rent without a
credit score and I hope it helps
just squash this myth and mythology that
you need a credit score to live your
life
gotcha I'm gonna I'm gonna make sure to
show my friends that then absolutely
well thanks for the call man and thank
you for your for your service in the
Navy that's awesome you sound like a
bright young man making fantastic money
let's get rid of all this debt get the
emergency fund begin Building Wealth for
the future and never look back
all right let's move on to Courtney in
Boise Courtney welcome to the show
thanks
how's it going um
it's it's it's going
um so I I have zero debt no credit score
so in my when they pull me credit score
it doesn't exist
um which is great I have a fully funded
um
emergency and and some money put aside
for a nice down payment I'm trying I'm
running into issues
um
being able to rent or especially buy
um because I've also
um
I've also simplified a lot of my um well
all of my bills so I'm I'm having issues
even qualifying for that manual on a
writing
and why is that have you asked them why
you're not qualifying
yeah so they said that uh they want four
at least four lines of um
bills so like um you know cell phone
insurance utilities yeah
um and uh I I
don't buy anything I I always uh try and
pay in cash right away so I don't have
those monthly payments so you're paying
in cash for like your electric bill and
your water bill
um yeah so
um I have my rent and my electric bill
all my other utilities are paved through
my
through rent
um and so they it only counts
as one level okay so how many lines do
you currently have
two you've got two so if we needed two
more are there other normal monthly
payments you're making like insurance
premiums anything like that
I don't have those monthly bills
um so I I can create I'm kind of I can't
create those uh monthly payments instead
of paying up front but like for instance
my um my internet I do prepaid because I
get it for quite a bit cheaper that way
um but then because it's prepaid that
doesn't count as a line okay what what
lender have you contacted so far for
this
um I've gone through
probably
I I've spoken to at least five different
lenders in my area okay have you tried
calling Churchill yet
um I have not
I would give them a shot call Churchill
Mortgage they're they're licensed in
your state and get their opinion on this
and they can give you some good hard
facts on exactly what you need to do to
do this in the shortest amount of time
possible you said you have full uh say a
down payment saved already
how much is that yeah I have
um I have uh just under 50 000. okay so
worst case you might need to rent and
keep these lines going for another six
to twelve months and then get the house
but it's only going to put you in a
better buying position when you have a
bigger down payment
it opens up your options so it stinks
that you're going through this I'm sorry
to hear that but uh get these these new
lines open you might need to switch to
monthly payments because that's what
they're looking for it's just consistent
monthly payments and if you have that
across those four lines you should be in
good shape to get this mortgage to the
manual underwriting process so wishing
you the best call our friends at
Churchill Mortgage they'll be happy to
help you tell them we sent you they'll
treat you right thanks for the call
Courtney this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
this is the Ramsay show our scripture of
the day comes from Lamentations 3 22-23
steadfast love of the Lord never ceases
his mercies never come to an end they
are new every morning great is your
faithfulness
Eleanor Roosevelt once said with the new
day comes new strength and new thoughts
Brent joins us up next in Salt Lake City
Brent welcome to the Ramsay show
glad to be here thanks for having me on
sure how can we help
okay
um I have some cash which it's about 55
000 all right in in my credit union
and
I'm really afraid of this economy the
way it sits right now so
um what are you afraid of
um the collapse
based on
yes
well yeah
in the past you know I mean in past
history the bank the government has come
in and shut down Banks and taking
people's money granted it's been
100 years ago basically you know I mean
it could happen couldn't it
Anything could happen but what's likely
to happen do you think all of your money
is going to disappear in that bank
well I have a lot more in that bank than
just this cash and it's insured correct
it's insured correct up to 250 000 per
person on the account per person do you
have more than that in one account
um well I have two separate accounts in
stocks
and
um well you can't be that scared since
all your money's there what's what's the
fear of driving all this all of a sudden
listen to all these YouTube videos yeah
so so that's yeah so Fear mongering
clickbait YouTube videos yeah I mean
listen if that's all you do is pay
attention to conspiracy theories and all
these things that could happen then it's
gonna absolutely uh impact you and and
so I don't want to Discount what your
fears are what you believe your
philosophies on government I'm not I
don't want to get down into that but I
would say this
the worst I mean you know you start
concocting the worst case scenario and
could it happen I guess who knows the
percentage chances you can't argue about
that because no one knows the percentage
chance of any of that happening but
could it happen sure but what do you I
mean living life requires you to make
some smart decisions based on
the realities of what's working the
stock market mutual fund performance all
that stuff has got history
um and and that's what you know but but
deciding what to do with your money
based on something that you don't know
is going to happen that doesn't get you
anywhere at all so unless you're
planning to go to a bunker somewhere and
and and you know live off of the
chickens and off grid and you know bury
your money in coffee tins
then then you know you know what to do
you know what to do with that money
yeah I know I I stopped watching the
YouTube apocalyptic videos first of all
that's why I've been watching you
instead that's good we're we gotta head
on our shoulders and uh we don't do
fearing you guys well what is there a
question underneath all of this that we
can help with today
well and I've got a I just retired and
now I've got a floral 1K that's gonna
I've got to do something with two pass
in a Roth and half is half of it's in a
traditional that you know do I take it
out or do I just leave it there and let
it ride
well do you need the money what are you
living off of right now no
um both my wife and I retired I just
retired the first or the end of December
uh combined we live off of about 8
000 a month and where does that come
from
um her retirement from the government
and my retirement from Social Security
and
um
so between the pension and social
security you guys aren't even touching
retirement accounts
oh no what's the total of your nest egg
two three
with our house because our house is paid
for basically what's the house worth
six was worth eight at the high peak so
600 000. what do you have in retirement
accounts
um
probably close to 400. okay
but it sounds like from the pension and
social security you guys are covered so
that 400 can continue to grow
yeah yeah
I just don't want to lose it well I mean
you'll have required minimum
distributions on those eventually if
they're on the traditional side
yeah so that's the only thing you'll
have to worry about
um but you're not going to lose it it's
not going to disappear into the abyss
worst case do you have any kids it'll be
passed down to
yes okay well that's a great blessing
and Legacy for them is it a good is it a
good thing to put uh set up a trust and
could ever get everything put into a
trust at this point in time if you'd
like to if there's a very specific way
you want this money distributed with
terms and conditions and some strings
attached then it's a wise thing to look
into
yeah yeah plus I have insurance you know
my life insurance and do you have a will
in place
we have a living will right now but it's
it's it's
fairly old we need to we need to do
something and update it I'm sure I'd get
all of that in order and I would sleep
well at night and get off the YouTube
channels Brent you're doing great you
guys have a great retirement income even
without touching those accounts but I
just let it ride and uh there's some
great tax strategies you can use with
the Roth versus traditional side so I'd
connect with a smart investor Pro if you
want to figure out how to best utilize
that money down the line all right let's
take a quick one here from Ann and we're
right up against the clock into the
question how can we help today
okay so I'm close to 60. my husband and
I we have zero debt we own our home free
and clear I still work we both still
work what do we do with our money
so the income you have coming in or do
you have savings
uh we have savings I currently
contribute 30 percent of
money in we have about 20 and just our
regular savings account
um and
um you know our living expenses are
practically nothing so I probably have
about 3 000 disposable a month great
well there's only three things you can
do with money at the end of the day give
it save it and spend it and I would
suggest you do all three and so find
something you're passionate about maybe
it's your local community local church
maybe it's a global Mission an
organization that's doing great work and
give there and then find some spending
goals do you guys do fun things do you
like to travel do you have any hobbies
you know we haven't done much of that we
say we're going to but we never do it I
know you're typing you guys have worked
so hard your whole life penny pinching
and it's hard to let go and enjoy some
of it and where do you want to go
um I want to go to Canada
where in Canada
I don't really know I'm thinking Quebec
I would like to go and see Canada
fantastic you're out in Seattle Larry
why don't you go up to Vancouver and
then make your way across the lovely
country and end up uh in uh Quebec very
French very fun but I mean start to map
this thing out let's go you got some
start to dream with your husband and go
what's all the things we haven't done
yet and might I suggest some place with
less rain and warmer temp there we go in
Seattle and then find some Hobbies if
there's something you've always wanted
to do or something you used to love to
do that you haven't had time to do
what's a hobby you'll want to do and I I
could say that I want to do that when I
retire but I'm still working and I'm
saving that for the retirement years
where I can give full 100 of uh donation
no my time to a cause which is when you
can do that part-time right now yeah
I can't I can't I got vacation time
right
I do when do you guys think you'll
retire
um I don't want to work until I'm 70. I
love it exactly what I do you're talking
to the right guy here with Ken Coleman
here that's a great thing as long as you
take some trips
hey you guys are doing great on the
saving side Anne and so I would just
look at give and spend side and go let's
have some goals where we force ourselves
to spend some money here and give some
there that will make you feel balanced
so you're not just penny pinching until
you go what did we do all this for let's
live like no one else that's what this
plan's about that puts this hour of the
Ramsay show in the books my thanks to
Ken Coleman all the guys in the booth
we've got Ben we've got Austin James
Zack Andrew everyone's in there and you
America you're out there listening and
we love you for it and we'll be back
real soon on the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
hey it's George camel if you like what
you heard in this episode and want to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]